at the beginning of easter week on
indonesia's sulawesi island
catholics in the city of makassar
gathered to mark palm sunday
unaware two bombers were waiting the
pair tried to enter the cathedral
through the main gate
but was stopped the attacker was trying
to enter our church
and one of our staff saw it and got
suspicious he then stood by the gate
and that's when the bomb exploded police
cordoned off the area
so far all police units are here
including the forensic team and also the
police chief
the president said all people in
indonesia have the right to worship in
peace
i strongly condemn this act of terrorism
and i have given instructions to the
police chief to investigate the networks
of the perpetrators to take down that
network to the root
in the early 2000s bomb attacks in
indonesia were more frequent
and killed many people but in recent
years authorities have increased their
crackdown
on active networks experts say the
threat has decreased
but not disappeared
the security apparatus actually created
maximum deterrence
but we know that these terror groups are
always finding new ways to avoid
security
in recent months police have made more
arrests and authorities are
investigating whether the attack might
have been a retaliation
against their operations jessica
washington al jazeera jakarta
well judith jacobs a southeast asia
security and political risk analyst
she says clandestine groups in indonesia
have repeatedly targeted churches in
recent years
there has been no immediate claim of
responsibility and i guess we're going
to have to wait for a definite answer
however churches are routinely targeted
by numerous militant islamist groups in
indonesia
for example in 2018 three churches were
attacked by
supporters of the jamaa ansharu dalla jd
a group that was formed by a radical
preacher called aman abdulrahman
generally security forces and local
security guards outside of religious
facilities are aware of the
threat posed by militant isms to
religious facilities
it is usually quite robust unfortunately
the determination of the attackers
persists i think that the government and
the security forces in
indonesia generally by and large do a
good job you'd see that
in february about 20 suspected jd
members
from makassar itself were arrested and
the police have been quite vigilant
throughout 2020 even with
the pandemic raging i think they've
arrested about 200 or so suspected
militants
throughout the country so they are doing
what is required of them but there will
always be individuals given that these
are clandestine organizations that
operate
in diffused cells um always ones that
will slip through the cracks
unfortunately